Er ist ein Querdenker –
und das, weil er die gesamte Logik
der Fast-Fashion-Industrie in Frage stellt.
Schneller, mehr, billiger ist für Sven Diestelow
nicht Ansporn für sein Handeln.
In erster Linie ist mir ganz wichtig,
dass niemand ausgebeutet wird.
Das ist schon mal wichtig.
Und zum anderen ist [da] natürlich
der Umweltaspekt, dass die Umwelt geschont
wird. Wir haben ja nur die eine Welt, ne.
Um sein ehrgeiziges Ziel zu erreichen,
geht er weiter als viele andere.
Es gibt ganz viele nachhaltige
Fashion Brands, aber bei den meisten
ist der Unterschied, dass wir es wirklich
innerhalb Europas versuchen –
vom Rohstoff bis zum fertigen Shirt
alles so regional – und hier meine ich die EU
ganz einfach mit – zusammenzuhalten.
Fashion made in Europe:
Der europäische Binnenmarkt
macht das leicht, oder?
Das will ich überprüfen, kaufe mir mein Shirt
100 Prozent made in Europe
und folge der Produktionskette.
Der erste Weg ist kurz.
Nur ein paar Kilometer entfernt befinden sich
die Büroräume und das Lager.
Hier wird der Vertrieb für den
Online-Shop organisiert.
Neue Kollektionen [werden] entworfen
und Schablonen gefertigt,
mit denen T-Shirts bedruckt werden.
Und auch für mein Shirt ist das
die letzte Station, bevor es ausgeliefert wird.
Von hier mache ich mich mit Sven Diestelow
auf den Weg nach Polen.
In Lodz betreibt er seine eigene Schneiderei
mit zehn Mitarbeitern
und will so seine eigenen Maßstäbe setzen.
Muss man wirklich ’n Kleidungsstück
20.000 Kilometer um die Welt schiffen?
Natürlich ist ’ne Fernost-Produktion viel, viel,
viel günstiger als das, was ich hier betreibe,
aber da kann ich ja auch
gar nichts beeinflussen.
Mit den Produktionsmengen
der Textilindustrie,
die außerhalb der EU produziert werden,
kann er nicht mithalten.
An seinem Standort hält er aber fest.
Hier, speziell in … im Umkreis von Lodz,
gibt es ’ne komplette Infrastruktur
für die Textilherstellung.
Textil besteht ja nicht nur aus ’nem Stoff
oder aus ’nem Nähgarn,
sondern man braucht Knöpfe, man braucht
Färbereien, man braucht Strickereien,
man braucht … viele, viele Dinge mehr wie
zum Beispiel auch mal ’nen Reißverschluss
oder Ähnliches, und all das gibt es hier.
Auch mein T-Shirt entsteht hier, wird aus dem
gefärbten Stoff zurechtgeschnitten,
zusammengenäht
und zu guter Letzt
für den Versand fertiggemacht.
In der Strickerei ums Eck entsteht
aus Garn der Stoff,
aus dem dann mein T-Shirt wird.
Und das geht in die ansässige Färberei.
Die Nähe zur Schneiderei soll
kurze Transportwege garantieren.
Und das Unternehmen muss sich
bei der Produktion in Polen
an europäische Umweltstandards halten.
Der Weg entlang der Produktionskette
meines Shirts führt mich weiter
nach Griechenland.
Von dort kommt nämlich die Baumwolle.
Zwar macht der Baumwollanbau des Landes
80 Prozent der gesamten
Baumwollproduktion der EU,
aber nicht einmal ein Prozent der weltweiten
Baumwollproduktion aus.
Der größte Teil der Baumwolle wird
also von weit her importiert.
Das Familienunternehmen Varvaressos
macht das anders.
Die griechische Garn-Spinnerei nutzt
die Baumwolle von Bauern aus dem Umland.
Und das hat seinen Preis.
Mein T-Shirt kostet ungefähr 20 Euro –
weit mehr als ein vergleichbares Shirt
der Fast-Fashion-Industrie.
Die Qualität hat auch ihren Wert.
Und wenn wir es nicht bezahlen möchten
als europäische Bürger,
dann muss es jemand in Asien bezahlen.
Bezahlen – in Form von harter Arbeit –
eine Folge des Fast-Fashion-Trends:
schneller und mehr produzieren,
damit wir weniger bezahlen.
Ein Trend, der auch dem griechischen
Familienunternehmen zu schaffen macht.
Dass es rückgängig
gegangen [zurückgegangen] ist
in den letzten Jahren,
hat mit den hohen Produktionskosten zu tun
und mit dem asiatischen Wettbewerb,
der zu sehr günstigen Preisen anbietet.
Wir arbeiten gerade daran
– und das ist unser Gedanke –,
also die gesamte Kette in Europa zu halten
und auch transparent zu sein.
Transparenz ist ein guter Weg,
neues Bewusstsein zu schaffen.
Doch das wird bestimmt nicht einfach.
Letztendlich liegt es an den Käufern,
ihr Konsumverhalten zu überdenken.
Mein neues T-Shirt aber beweist,
dass es funktionieren kann:
Fair Fashion made in Europe.